Sweetheart. Wow.
I never sleep during the day.
I've slept through a few, but I don't
nap.
Come on. I got something I want to show
you. Jump on your horse.
This is more your kind of beautiful.
I found it a year ago.
And you said you wanted to be married
in a place with no memories that we
made em'.
I kind of rushed the wedding, didn't I?
I'm sorry, baby.
Yeah. In my defense, I thought I was
going to spend the rest of my life in
prison, so.
And I had to put the pedal to the
metal.
F*** you.
You're a good man.
You. Thank you.
All I need now is a cigarette.
You know I'm blowing you anyway.
You don't have to work so f***ing hard.
Here you are a perfect motherf*****.
I could do this.
I could live here and never see another
person in my whole life.
Except you.
Yeah, it might be a little tricky in the
winter, sweetheart.
No, you know what I mean.
I mean, I don't. I don't need anything
else. Cigarettes, whiskey, a meadow.
And, you.
Darling, you have a warped sense of
priorities, I'll tell you.
No, I don't.
Three things that make me feel good in
the perfect meadow.
I don't need anything else.
Do you? All right.
You can have a horse.
Well, I need cows to chase her.
There's no reason to ride em.
Fine, you can have a couple of cows.
Okay. Thank you.
Now, are you going to need some place to
chase him too, Right?
You're going to make me build a barn in
my perfect meadow.
Beth. No, you know, stop applying logic
to my perfect daydream.
Please shut the f*** up.
Shut the f*** up and watch that sunset
with me. Shut the f*** up!
Shut the f*** up! He says to his wife.
Not shut up. Shut the f*** up.
You know.
F*** your sunset, baby.
You watch me.
Sunsets are overrated anyway.